on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
[Applaudissements]
je veux dire quoi annie aime les
sucettes à l'anis ça veut rien dire ma
chaise à lagny
grand-mère de son à la télé il a dit
nash pho ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que c'est une nymphe a investi 9 au
masculin comme hambourg le moins et
grand-mère info adamou c'est à dire une
information et
[Rires]
grand mère oui adam en séries ça veut
dire quoi adamo a traité des mots ça
veut dire ça chanteur belge est d'accord
les grands-mères comment vivre un joint
alors ça et je ne sais pas si je vais
bien je ne sais pas du tout est clair
oui quoi papa il a fait un bisou sur la
bouche à la baby sitter il a fait ça
je verrai si
j'ai un coup terrible à provoquer la
grand mère oui ma soeur elle a dit
[ __ ] ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que c'est quelqu'un qui vous prend par
l'arrière
grand mère pourquoi chirac m'a dit oui
le président de la république il paraît
qu'il est convoqué chez le juge il veut
pas y aller pourquoi
et puis et puis johnny hallyday il a une
mercedes et puis toi tu n'as pas grand
mère pourquoi parce que on a sept
français
et grand mère oui papa il est était sur
le lit il est monté sur la baby sitter
et puis ça lui a fait mal à la publicité
à la tête pas de crier pourquoi elle
criait grand mère
parce qu'ils se rendent pas compte qu'il
est lourd
j'aimerais bien
oui pourquoi dieu là il n'y a pas de
femmes
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu